more than a dozen former senior
intelligence officials are sharply
criticizing presidents Trump's decision
to pull former CIA director John Brennan
security clearance a letter first
reported by CBS News calls it
inappropriate and deeply regrettable it
claims the president's decision quote
has nothing to do with who should and
should not hold security clearances and
everything to do with an attempt to
stifle free speech CBS News senior
national security contributor Michael
Morell is one of those who sign that
letter
he's a former CIA acting director and
deputy director Michael good morning
good morning John what is the key danger
of what the president did in your view
John I was not just a signer of this
letter I was one of the organizers and I
will tell you that it was difficult to
get the language just right because
there were those of us who believe that
what John has done since he left
government and how he has chosen to use
his voice is appropriate and actually
required in a democracy and there are
those of us who believe that he is
acting inconsistent with the stature of
a former director so it was tough to get
that language right but what we all
agreed on was two things one is that
John is a patriot that he worked his
entire life to keep the country safe
that there are Americans who are alive
today that wouldn't be if John had not
served in government and we did none of
us like the allegations that were being
made against him by the White House and
by some members of Congress including
Senator Paul the other thing we agreed
on John is that the use of a national
security tool for political purposes is
inappropriate unprecedented and
dangerous in a democracy dangerous how
is this a national security issue so
it's not I John it's not a national
security issue its dangers in that there
are individuals on many on the national
security side who want to criticize the
government's policies
who were supportive and some who want to
criticize some who want to criticize the
president and this in our view was an
intent to intimidate them and the the
risk here is that a number of people
will no longer speak out because they'll
be afraid of the president taking action
against them Mike Jim clapper one of the
people on the list of security
clearances the president is considering
lifting said that he is currently
advising members of the Trump
administration right now as we speak he
didn't want to name them what does that
tell you about the president in his
State of Mind now is he aware that he
could actually be shooting himself and
the country's security and the foot it's
a great question because the purpose the
reason that former senior officials
maintain these clearances is that not
for their own benefit but that they can
advise the current government and I do
that all the time I've been on two
commissions since since I retired and
I'm I advised senior officials all the
time many as do many of the others on
the list so this is actually a loss for
the government not for the individuals
all right Michael Morell we thank you
for joining us this morning welcome